hey 42 here in the beginning there was
nothing which exploded that's how the
great Terry Pratchett described the
beginning of the universe the legendary
Big Bang the majority of modern physics
comes from the understanding that
everything started out as one tiny tiny
point that blew up expanded and created
all the wonderful things around you like
galaxies stars planets and bacon
sandwiches as a planet we're pretty set
on this concept but that's not to say
it's the only possibility that's been
suggested obviously you have the many
religious creation stories but even
within the scientific community a few
other options have been put forward so
if you've ever wondered whether our
universe is actually all a cat's dream a
marble in the hand of a giant alien or a
simulation that has some worrying coding
errors well then here are some
alternative and entirely possible
theories to the Big Bang our first idea
is born out of string theory and
popularized by
Steinhardt aunt Erick who sound like a
German techno der ER string theory is
basically an attempt to connect the
ideas of general relativity with the
bizarre and confusing world of quantum
mechanics the idea is that there are
many more dimensions than the ones we
can currently observe and that's
something that might look like a point
from our perspective is actually just a
part of a long long string like you are
looking at a bit of spaghetti dead on
and mistaken it for a tiny speck the
Steingarten Turing proposed an idea
called the incredible bull it's not
being entirely rejected by the physics
community but possibly because they are
afraid of making the incredible board
angry you wouldn't like it when it's
angry it suggests that rather than there
being one big bang our observable
universe is like a sheet of paper
drifting in a multi-dimensional soup a
furious Collies sheets
brains short for membrane
occasionally our brain collides with
another brain and there is a big release
of energy there is supposedly an endless
cycle of collisions and expanding brains
and our entire universe came from just
one of these collisions Sean Carroll has
been obsessed with time since he was
young his problem of the Big Bang was
not that it came at the beginning of
time but that time itself has a
beginning and an end why does time only
move in one direction well what if there
were multiple universes and in some of
them time runs backwards Sean Carroll
studies multiverses and how they relate
to dark energy in the multiverse theory
a universe can spring up from the random
fluctuations in dark energy which
appears throughout what we think of as
empty space dark energy is kind of like
glitter it gets bloody everywhere
sometimes these randomly created
universes within the multiverse wouldn't
really get going and they collapse into
a black hole but very occasionally one
such as our own takes off and expands
rapidly it keeps expanding forever and
eventually become so findout that it is
now the empty space where another
universe can form within it now how's
that for an inception or Mindbender one
of the confusing things about the
universe is that it looked basically the
same in all directions no matter where
you're looking from since we know the
universe is expanding we tend to think
of it as a balloon but for most of us
this gives the idea of a center and an
edge which is not really the case Fred
Hoyle tried to explain this similarity
of all parts of the universe with an
idea called steady-state if you want to
keep the density of stuff the same in an
expanding space surely you need to keep
adding things or the density will
decrease it's like a house party if
people keep arriving you're going to
need to keep adding booze
otherwise everyone will start getting
bored and possibly drinking all your
perfume and cleaning products and that
won't end well trust me in order to keep
the density or matter would need to be
spontaneous
created and before you start picturing
random bubbles of hydrogen appearing all
around you the amount suggested by Fred
Hoyle was about one atom a year within
each cubic kilometer so if you go out of
your way trying to find these new
spontaneously created atoms it might
take you quite a while you're better off
just going to find some Pokemon or
something speaking of running out of
space in Christoph rhetorics theory we
are all heading towards a big game of
galactic sardines
since rather than expanding the walls
are actually closing in others he called
this the cold bang one of the big
observable factors for why we believe
the universe is expanding is the Doppler
effect or redshift we noticed that very
distant galaxies seem to be redder than
closer ones and this was true wherever
we looked so unless we were surrounded
by a gigantic red light district there
must be some reason for this and there
is even object is giving out a
wavelength like light or sound then it's
movement affects how you the observer
receives that wave if it's moving
towards you then the waves are pushed
together at a higher frequency if the
object is moving away then they are
stretched out and become a lower
frequency you can hear this effect of a
police siren the person repeats quicker
as the sirens come nearer and it gets
higher pitched and then seems to slow
down as it moves off into the distance
unless you're being arrested again in
which case you'll only get the first
part so if the universe is expanding
then light from distant objects is being
stretched since they are moving away
from us so it has a longer wavelength
making it redder
so rhetoric things that the universe
isn't expanding but the mass of
everything inside the universe is simply
getting greater the benefit of his
theory is that it avoids the need for
everything starting from a singularity
which is always caused a bit of trouble
the problem with it though is that
there's going to be much less space on
the beach in a few trillion years
another factor of existence that is
difficult to explain is why everywhere
is
relatively even temperature sure it may
not feel like that here on earth where
you can get brain free to my screen one
minute and then the next minute burn
your mouth on apple pie but on a general
level like if you cut the universe up in
two cubic light-years they are all
roughly the same temperature blood a
cosmic scale the universe is still just
a toddler wetting the bed and drawing
all over the world in crayon the Big
Bang was astonishingly hot so you'd
expect there to be more hot pockets and
I'm not talking about that snack that
sort of resembles food some theorists
have wondered if maybe there is some
unknown energy that caused an expansion
faster than the speed of light which
would explain how the temperature evened
out so quickly near of Shirdi and his
team came up with the idea that perhaps
our freedy universe was not only in a 4d
bulk universe like we'd discussed
earlier but one that actually created 4d
stars and if you have 4d stars then
these can collapse into 4d black holes
so perhaps we are all like sheets of
paper wrapped around the event horizon
of one of these great black holes
sucking up the enormous energy that
would be surrounding us thanks to the
work of great minds all over the world
we are learning more and more about what
is out there and how it began from the
quantum madness of the Large Hadron
Collider to the gravitational waves of
dancing black holes found by the
advanced LIGO project but perhaps the
true origins of the universe are
something we will never be able to prove
and maybe we don't really want to know I
mean how would you feel if you knew that
we were just a tiny tiny insignificant
planet in one of many tiny tiny
insignificant universes kind of scary
isn't it
or perhaps if the Big Bang was just as
sneezes some eight dimensional cut
actually I'm pretty fine with that last
one
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 think back to the last time
you had an apple when do you think it
was picked a couple of days ago a couple
of weeks ago perhaps try a year ago why
is a 1.2 square kilometer island
called Hans Island and Canada in Denmark
just can't help put their sticky hands
all over